this course will help someone with no
technical knowledge
understand how the internet works ian
frost
teaches this course with tons of visuals
just like he has taught
thousands of people on udemy the
internet
is a part of our daily life and we use
it constantly
but what is the internet have you ever
really thought about it
have you ever wondered what happens in
the background
when you enter a web page if your answer
to all these questions
is yes you are definitely looking at the
right course in this course
i assume you don't know anything and i
am slowly explaining
what the internet is you don't need any
prior knowledge
to follow this course since this course
tells you everything from scratch
with many abstractions these
abstractions
will allow you to understand the subject
without knowing
details i think everyone who uses the
internet
should know its basic features everyone
who uses the internet
needs to know the isp everyone who uses
the internet needs to know that
the internet is just cables spread
all over the world and in this course we
will go on a journey together
and we will look at all these concepts
in a very visual way
i mean you will see exactly how the
internet works
with your eyes in addition at the end of
the course there are some questions
related to this course and by answering
them you can benefit from this course
at the maximum level okay regardless of
your age or profession
this course is for everyone you will
absolutely understand what the internet
is
when you finish this course so let's
dive into it
now we are going to talk about a
scenario
let's say you are the system
administrator of a small company
and your boss wants you to enable all
these computers
to communicate with each other i mean
pc1
should be able to communicate with pc7
or
pc5 should be able to communicate with
pc4
and so on you got the point but the
question is
how do we do such a task and this is
where
the switch device comes into play the
switch is the device we use
for computers in the same environment to
communicate with each other
when i say in the same environment what
i mean is that
i'm talking about computers in the same
office
house or at very close distance to each
other
and this scenario is a good example for
such a situation
there's an office and in this office we
have seven computers that
communication of time is required
wonderful
we have a switch to accomplish the
communication of computers
this is good however the question is
can these 7 computers communicate with
each other right now
and the answer is big no
because first of all these 7 computers
need to interact with the switch somehow
but
how can we do that i know that you have
some ideas
and you are probably guessing right we
must use
cables to connect computers to the
switch
as you can see we are connecting all the
computers to the switch
with the help of cables we generally use
copper cables for this task
and the type of these copper cables can
generally be cat5 cable
or k6 cable in small environments
by the way cat6 cables are faster than
cat5 cables
and cat represents category okay
on the other hand in addition to copper
cables
some switches support fiber optic cables
as well
and it is important to note that fiber
optic cables
are generally much faster compared to
copper cables
in data transmission this is very
important
and for switch devices
there is a crucial point to be aware of
please
note that if there's a switch in the
environment
and if you want to connect computers to
that switch
we must definitely use a cable that is
generally a copper cable
or fiber optic cable what i am trying to
say is
with wireless technology you cannot
connect computers
to a switch switches only work with
cables
this is very vital guys if you want to
use a switch device
you have to use cable to connect your
devices
to the switch it's that simple however
if you want to connect computers in the
same environment to each other
by using all wireless technology you can
use an
access point device instead of a switch
device
i mean you can use both a switch device
or an access point twice
in order to connect all the seven
computers both of them separately is
acceptable for this purpose
the only difference between these
devices is access points use
wireless technology while switches use
cables
okay there are seven computers in this
environment
and we can connect these seven computers
by using switches and cables
just like you see in the picture or in
the same way
we can use an access point device
instead of a switch device
and if you use an access point device
access point uses
wireless technology instead of cables
while communicating
with devices in summary both the switch
device or an access point device
enable these seven computers to
communicate this is obvious
but one uses cable and the other one
uses
wireless technology anyway what i just
want you to know right now
is we generally use copper cables in
order to connect
computers to the switch in the
environment such as a hump
or office by the way i want to focus on
the switch device
instead of the access point twice in
this course
very good and at this moment
all these computers can communicate with
each other with ears
because they connected to the switch by
using cables
and this means that they created a
network
in other words the reason that these
computers can communicate with each
other
is all of them are in the same network
and we call this special network as
local area network
or briefly lan a local area network is a
collection of devices
connected together in non-physical
location such as a building
office or home as i just said if you
want to create
a lan this location must be a restricted
location in terms of
area i mean you cannot create a lan
between computers
located in united states and computers
located in russia
on the other hand this area is very
suitable area
in order to create a lan therefore these
computers
can communicate with each other because
all of them
are on the same lan with the help of
this switch
so we can deduce that if we want to
create
a lan we need a switch device by using a
switch device
we can create a local area network
and if we consider the millions of local
area network all over the world
we can easily understand how important a
switch device is
you might think that all the houses in
the world are
actually a local area network you have a
land
in your house or your neighbor's home
also has a land
or there is also a lan in the office
where you work okay
you catch the idea and now
let's take a closer look at the
communication of computers
and what this event actually represent
let's say
pc1 wants to send a message to the pc6
by the way the messages generated by
computers
has a few special names some people call
them
as packet and some people call them
as frame both of them is okay but in
this course
i prefer to use packet instead of frame
okay pc1 will send a packet to the pc6
as you see individual the packet firstly
goes to the switch
and then the sewage looks at the inside
of the packet
and learns the destination of the packet
and finally
the switch sends the packet to its
destination
and if pc1 can send a packet to the pc6
this means that pc1 and pc6 can
communicate with each other
the logic is basically this if a
computer can send a packet
to another computer this refers to
these two computers are on the same
network and they can communicate with
each other
this information is so crucial guys
okay however maybe by looking at
only this switch image what the switch
device actually is
may not be fully visualized in your mind
for this reason
we will now examine this slide for you
to understand the event better
this is the real version of a service
device and
as you can see there are many parts
on a switch device this is important
also the number of ports
varies from one switch device to another
switch device i mean
different switches have different
numbers of parts
some switches have temp ports while some
switches
have more than 20 parts and of course
this generally leads to an increase
in price okay by the way
these parts have a special name and they
are called
lampards this probably makes sense to
you because as you know
we create lands by using switch devices
for this reason i think it is so
reasonable to call these parts lan ports
because by connecting these computers to
these parts
we can create a lan and in addition to
this
there are lan ports on the back of our
computers
or on the side of our laptops
just like these lamppods you can see the
related visuals
on the right side
and to establish a connection between
computers and
switch we connect the lan port on the
computer
and the lan port on the switch with the
help of a cable
so let's do this let's start with this
port
and pc1 then let's connect this part
and piece it after that let's connect
this port and pc3
and finally i want to make a connection
between this part
and pc4 wonderful
and currently these computers can
communicate with each other
but how exactly does this communication
happen
from a switch perspective let's take a
look at this
let's say pc1 wants to communicate with
pc4
so it will send a packet to the pcfr
this packet will go to this part of the
switch first
and there we go afterward
that part will give the packet to the
hardware inside the switch
okay then this switch will look inside
this packet
and learns its destination after that
the switch gives this packet to this
port that is connected to pc4
and finally the switch sends the packet
to the pc4 okay wonderful
and to summarize currently we have
connected these four computers to each
other
thanks to the switch this means we have
created a local area network
and these computers can easily
communicate with each other
since they're on the same lan i hope
everything is quite good so far
and the switch device is visualized
better in your mind
thanks to this slide but there is a
little issue here
let me explain if you are aware our
computers
were in the same network and we have
only talked about
the communication between those devices
we have never talked about
how these computers can connect to the
internet
right so the question is can these
computers
communicate with the internet just by
having a switch device
and this my friends will be the question
that we are looking for an answer
in the next lesson see you guys soon
bye
in our previous lesson we briefly talked
about
how to connect computers in an office
and how do we create a network
and i said that we can create a lan with
the help of a search device
but the problem is currently these
computers
can only communicate among themselves
they cannot communicate
with the internet because the only task
of the switch
is to create a lan and enable the
communication of the devices
in the same lan great and by the way
i would like to remove this line
statement from the visual because
you can understand that there's a lan
here thus
we can work more comfortably wonderful
and the main question is
how do we connect these computers to the
internet
and this is where the router device
comes into play
let me explain the main task of the
router is
to enable computers to connect to the
internet
without a router it is impossible for us
to connect to the internet and in order
to provide this connection
i mean in order to provide a connection
to the internet
first of all we must connect this switch
to this router
and this cable is a copper cable just
like other cables
this is good but currently what we have
to do
isn't over we still can't connect to the
internet in this situation
because we need a connection between the
rotor
and the internet as well and as you know
a special cable comes to our homes or
offices
and this cable is given us by internet
service provider
and thanks to the disk cable we connect
to the internet if you have never heard
of
internet service provider don't worry we
will talk about it in detail but for now
all you need to know is the internet
service provider is giving us
this cable for a certain amount of money
so that
we can connect to the internet easily
okay
so currently we have everything
necessary
to connect to the internet by using
these computers
hence let's see the basic tasks of the
switch and router one by one
on the animation these seven computers
in the office
can communicate with each other thanks
to the switch for example let's say
pc1 wants to communicate with pc5 for
this purpose
pc1 will send a packet to the pc5
so easy now the packet firstly goes to
the switch
and afterwards the switch learns the
destination of the packet
and finally the switch sends the packet
to its destination and there we go
this is how two computers in the same
lan communicate with each other
and please always remember a switch
device
is enough for us in order for
communication of devices
in the same lan on the other hand a
router
has no role in the communication of
different devices
in the same lan like pc1 and pc5
this is very vital ok i hope i could
explain the event
and however guys what if
pc1 was to communicate with the internet
in other words
what will happen if pc1 was to send a
packet
to the internet let's see
first of all you should remember this
information
if a computer can send packets to the
internet
this means that this computer
communicates with the internet
frankly speaking i believe that you
exactly understand
the logic of this event anymore if we
can send packets
from one point to another point these
two points
can communicate it's that simple but the
question is
how will pc1 send packets to the
internet
to be able to do this first pc1 must set
its packet to the switch
just like before because there is no
other way for pc1
to be able to reach the router right i
mean if pc1
wants to send a packet to the internet
this packet
must reach the router no matter what
because the router
is a door to access the internet this is
obvious
hence if pc1 wants to communicate
with the router it must send its packet
to the switch first after that the
switch looks at
inside of the packet and understand that
the packet
wants to go to the internet so it sends
the packet
to the router and there we go
and then the router firstly looks at the
inside of the packet
and understand that the packet wants to
go to the internet
and afterward it sends the package to
the internet
over this part and there we go
by the way if you are aware we have
plugged this cable
that we purchased from the isp into this
part this is obvious
i believe that currently you can easily
imagine in an
intuitive manner how the cables coming
to the router
like this or like this are plugged into
the parts
i mean there are some ports on the
router and
you need to put the cables into that box
it's that simple
i will not show this regionally because
detailed information about the parts
isn't important for you at this moment
you just must
understand the logic behind the router
okay
and as a result pc1 sent its packet
to the internet in other words pc1 and
the internet
communicated and the device that helped
us to connect to the internet
is the router wonderful
i believe that you understand the most
basic tasks
of the sewage and router and i hope
the animations have been useful for
better understanding
however i want to ask you two questions
my first question is can you visualize
the internet
in your mind and the second question is
what exactly does the internet mean
and these will be the questions that we
are going to discuss
in the next lessons see you guys soon
before discussing the meaning of
connecting to the internet
from a computer perspective i think it
is helpful to know what the internet
exactly stands for because if you are
really starting from scratch
i mean i assume that you are real
newbies
you may not know exactly what the
internet is
for this reason i want to visualize the
internet
for better understanding to do this in
this lesson
we are going to see how a packet moves
on the internet by the way keep in mind
that
this model you see is a simplified model
designed
to make the concept easier to understand
so
this structure in real life is much more
complex than you see
individual but with this simplified
model
you will understand the logic of the
event very well i promise you
and i believe that's all you need right
now
as you can see there are many writers
on the internet right and there's a
special reason for this
so at this moment i would like to give
you
another piece of information about a
router
a router is a device required for a
computer
or electronic device to connect to the
internet
you know this definition on the other
hand you can think of the router
as the device we use to communicate with
your computer
in another part of the world or you can
think of the router
as the device we use to communicate with
the computer
in a different plan i mean if you are
aware
there is a land here right and there is
another land here this is
obvious therefore we can draw the
following conclusion
connecting to the internet actually can
stand for
connecting to the another computer
located
anywhere in the world i mean you can
think of the internet
is the structure that connects all the
lands
all over the world i want to repeat this
again
you can think of the internet as a
structure that
connects old lands all over the world
and as you know there are millions of
lands
connected to the internet except these
lands
wonderful i hope that everything is good
so far
but there's a thing that we need to
consider so
i want to ask you a question why are
there
so many routers here let me explain it
in a simple manner first
you should know that these routers are
distributed around the world
in an organized manner however
routers aren't the only devices in this
structure this is important
there are thousands of routers and
other different devices in this
structure distributed pretty widely
but focusing on only writers is enough
for us in order to understand
the concept behind the internet and
the first question that comes to your
mind is probably
why routers are so important to the
internet
as a matter of fact the answer to this
question is
hidden in the core task of a router the
device we use to enable different plans
to communicate with each other is
drought right
and thanks to the internet we can
connect all the lands in the world
to each other you know for this reason
it makes perfect sense to use
many routers to connect millions of
local area networks together
these lands you see are just two of the
millions of local area networks
all over the world in summary if the
internet
must connect millions of local area
networks it is obvious that
it needs routers i hope you got this
and once you understand the importance
of the router for the internet
you probably think of another question
and the second question that probably
comes to your mind
is why there are so many writers
instead of just one writer and i think
this is a more critical question
than the first question and let me
answer it
on the visual but before answering this
question
there is something in this picture that
should catch your attention
please look carefully at the picture and
try to find
this difference
as you can see these lines on the visual
have one device instead of a sewage and
a router so if there is no switch
in the environment how can there be a
lan
or if there is no router in the
environment
how can it be connected to the internet
and this is where
the home router comes into play a home
router is a combat device
consisting of a router and switch
combination
hence these devices in the lens are a
mix of the switch
and router this means that if we have a
home router
we don't need an additional switch and
router
this device is enough for small
environments
like a home or small office this is
important
i want to repeat this again a home
router is enough for us
in small environments or if there are
very few devices in the environment okay
i showed you home router because most of
you
have these devices in your home and you
connect to the internet
by using home routers for this reason i
wanted to tell you
what these devices are in order to avoid
confusion
however please note that if there are
too many devices
in the environment the home router will
be insufficient
and you may need additional switch and
router
you catch the idea and now let's go back
to our question
why there are so many routers instead of
just a single router imagine that
there is a single router in the middle
of the world instead of
thousands of routers distributed all
over the world
in this case millions of electronic
devices around the world
would have to be connected to the same
router this is obvious this means that
this single router needs millions of
parts
isn't it and it is impossible to design
such a device
but this is not the only problem in
addition to it
if there was only one router the entire
lot of the all devices in the world
would be on that router and this is
another problem because
in computer science we don't want to
give all the lot
on a single point we even call this
problem
the single point of failure and this is
a problem that
needs to be considered to be able to
teach it better
let me give you an example imagine this
router is broken somehow
this means that the internet of the
whole world
is crashing down at the same time right
because we only use
a single router to connect all lands
around the world
the rotor broke down and the whole
internet crashed down
it's that simple just think about the
consequences
of this problem in a second this would
be terrible
right and so far we have talked about
two vital problems
but it isn't over another major problems
is the cable length problem imagine
how long the cable must be if there was
only one giant router
in the middle of the world especially
lands
that are the furthest from the giant
router will need very long cables this
is obvious
right therefore this design is a very
problematic design
and the solution for all these problems
is
this distributed structure all over the
world
you catch the idea but to make sure you
fully understand the main logic of this
structure
i want you to do an exercise i want you
to determine
why such a structure eliminates the
problems we talked about shortly before
i'm sure that you can handle this just
do it guys
i asked you a question at the end of the
previous lesson
and i know that you were all analyzing
the situation
but let's do it together just in case as
you know
if we used a single router at the middle
of the world
we would have problems with the
overloading of the router
on the other hand we would need many
long cables for lens
that are the furthest from the giant
router but
as you can see in this structure the
cables
don't have to be that long and this is
an important advantage
actually of course we can need long
cables
in this structure too but not as much as
in the other structure
after all in this structure there can be
many kilometers
between two routers this is reasonable
however
this is by no means laying cables from
one end of the world to the other end
right
and while we only connect two routers
with
one cable in this structure we will
connect millions of lamps
to the giant router in the other
structure so
we will need a lot of very long cables
to a single point
and it creates a huge mass imagine
cables coming to the giant router from
millions of lamps
that locate in the furthest area you got
the point
by using this structure we minimize the
cable mass
and we avoid overloading of a router
everything is good but what about the
load overloading
since there are many routers load
balance process
is very efficient in the distributed
structure i mean
this system works very well and in
addition to load balancing
it solves the single point of failure
problem as well
for example this router this router
this router and this router are broken
somehow
in this case the internet continues to
work properly
right only its efficiency decreases a
bit
on the other hand when there is only one
router
and if this router is broken the whole
internet crashes down and
this was very bad so i believe that
consistency is very important for such a
huge structure
like the internet and now
i want to show you a visual that shows
the cables
between different countries and
different continents
with this visual you will understand
much better
what the internet is these cables
are very important especially for the
communication of countries
that there is an ocean between them and
this visual represents real life itself
unlike the simplified model we use 99
of all international communication on
the internet
is provided by these 468 cable lines
laid under the water this is very
crucial guys
some of these cables are only 131
kilometers long
while others are around 20 000
kilometers long
and so on and the funny thing is
breaking one of these cables
can cause the internet of the whole
continent
to go away in a flash time in fact
it was happened such an event in 2018
and i want to show this on a different
image okay
i want you to focus on this red cable
this is an almost 17 000 long cable
that starts in france and reaches south
africa
and this cable connects 22 countries
on the west coast of europe and africa
to each other
and to the internet and the internet of
10 of these countries
crashed down when a fishing boat
accidentally cut the cable
and i think this was a definitely
tragicomic event
in addition to this as you can imagine
this is not the only problem that
happens
to cables because we are talking about 1
million kilometer long cables
spread all over the world so there must
be
something more as a matter of fact
nearly 200
problems are encountered each year and
these are substantially related to the
ships
or natural disasters and there's a final
reason that
i prefer to use substantially word
let me explain in 2007
sea pirates stole 11 kilometers of a
cable
connecting thailand vietnam and hong
kong to each other
and they sold this long cable as scrap
by dividing it and i think this event is
more surprising
than the incredible infrastructure of
the internet
now i have back to the first slide
because there is something
i want to show here these colorful
cables
generally represent intercontinental
connections
under waters but for example if you look
at
russia land cables are not visible
on this image please don't be confused
about it
of course there are cables and routers
distributed all over russia too
they are just ignored in this image i
mean the main purpose of this image
was to show you how devices from
different continents
are interconnected under the water okay
also note that all of these cables under
waters
are fiber optic cables because the
fastest data transmission cable type
is fiber of the cables and
intercontinental data transmission
must occur at the highest bit right
and another reason of why we don't use
copper cables
is when the length of the copper cables
increases
the probability of errors in data
transmission
increases as well on the other hand even
if the fiber optic cables are very long
they transmit the data to its
destination
almost without ever and this is another
reason that
wi-fi blocked cables are used over long
distances
great i think it is important for you to
understand
what the internet really is it is very
vital to be able to visualize it
in your mind because no matter what area
of it you are dealing with
you need to grasp this basic subject
actually
there was something else i wanted to
show in this lesson
but i don't want to extend this lesson
any further
we will continue where we left off in
the next lesson
that will be a very important lesson see
you guys
in a moment
in this lesson we are going to discuss
how a packet moves
over the internet in this way you will
understand
how two devices in different countries
communicate with each other
we will see this on an example let's say
this computer in lan 1
was to communicate with this computer in
lantern
okay in other words let's assume that
this computer
was to send a special packet to this
computer
so this packet must go to the disrupter
to exit from the land run you know
because our destination is the out of
landman i mean it is a different network
our destination
is on lantern and we can send our
package
over the internet to lanter and now
we are going to do this exactly first
this computer sends the packet to the
switch
after the switch receives the package
the switch looks at the destination
address of the packet
and understand that it has to send the
packet
to the router and after the router
receives the packet
the router looks at the content of it
and learns
its destination address hence it
understand that it must set the packet
to the internet because the destination
of the packet
is in a different network than lan one
so
the router must set the packet to this
router
that is connected because this router is
the key router for line 1
to connect to the internet i mean if
this router
needs to send a packet to the internet
it must send the packet
to this router no matter what there is
no other option
right and you can think of this link
as the connection of lan1 to the
internet
and if this link is cut somehow the
devices in lan
1 cannot access the internet it's that
simple
after this point things will get a
little complicated
so please listen to me very carefully
after packet
reaches this router the packet has three
options to go
this part this pad or dispatch right
this is obvious but the question
is which path is better option to go for
the packet
and in order to answer this question
first
we need to discuss what the routing
table is
each router must have a special table
inside
called routing table and after receiving
a packet
a router looks at its routing table to
learn
which path it must send the packet for
this router
it should be this pad this pad or this
pad
right this is obvious and if you are
aware
firstly the router receives the packet
from
one of its parts i hope that you can
imagine
all these cables that come counted
router are
plugged into a port on the router very
good
and after the router receives the packet
the router
learns the destination of the packet and
sends the packet
to an appropriate port according to the
information
on the routing table and we call this
operation
forwarding as a result every router
needs to look at its routing table to
learn
which path it must forward the packet in
other words
we can easily understand that routing
tables
need to have information that which path
a packet will got
okay it is very important to know this
fundamental task
of the routing table each router
has a special processor and information
in the routing table
is created by this special processor
using many different algorithms these
algorithms
determine the part that a packet must go
and
the results of these algorithms are
added
to the routing table okay as a result
this router will look at its routing
table and learn
which part the packet must be forwarded
one
two or three meanwhile when a router
makes this decision it always ignores
the path that
the packet came from because it makes no
sense
to forward the packet back the way it
came from
right and let's say according to the
routing table of this router
the packet must be forwarded over path 3
and there we go after that
this router needs to look at its routing
table to decide
which path the packet must go to assume
that the routing table saves the packet
must be forwarded over patter so
the packet will go to this router right
and there we go
if you are aware the event is always the
same
and it will continue to be the same in
every router
until the packet reaches lanter anyway
let's keep going where we left off this
router
must look at its routing table to
determine which path the packet will be
forwarded
let's say the router choose that one
so the packet will go to this router
right
wonderful and at this moment
please listen to me very carefully
because there's a tricky part here
when you look at the password current
position of the packet
you probably think of the most
reasonable option expecter
because the shortest path to be able to
access this router
that is connected to this router seems
to be factor
right and if we choose patch one for
example
we have to go to this router first and
from here
we can go to this router or
if we choose pad 3 we will go to this
router first and from here
we can go to this router similarly but
if we
choose part 2 we can go directly
to this router and this is what we want
but is this really the case let's see
together
first of all never forget that routers
always want to deliver the packet to its
destination
as fast as possible so if this router
chooses pad 3 instead of pad 2 it may
seem unreasonable to you
at the beginning i understand that
because
you decide with a very simple logic you
are just using your eyes
however routers use many algorithms
when creating their routing tables and
these algorithms
have many variables i mean routers
have to take into account many
situations when they are creating
routing tables
for example let's call every router
as a point in this structure okay
so when routers create their routing
tables
they are not only concerned with the
number of points
when choosing the shortest route to the
destination
this is really very important and i want
to give an example to you
to understand this subject better in
some cases
routers control the traffic of their
links
they are connected to and if a path is
too busy
in terms of packet density the router
will not send the packet
over that part i mean for instance there
may be an excessive density
on the part 2 line even if it seems the
best option
okay and since the router knows
this line is too busy when creating its
routing table
it may decide that it is more convenient
to set the packet
over pad 3 instead of patter and
we call this situation congestion
control
ok i think that i could get to the point
as a result the router sells the packet
over pad 3 and here we go as you can see
the number of points that the packet
went through
has increased however with the selection
of pad 3
the package can probably reach its
destination faster
don't forget this and after this moment
let the packet go to this router and
there we go
and this router knows that the packet
will go to the lantern and it sends the
packet
to the router in the home okay by the
way you can think of this line
as a straight line like that and
this router knows that the packet came
to this computer
so it sends the packet to the related
computer
wonderful as you can see two devices
located in distant areas basically
communicate with each other
thanks to the internet we can
communicate in milliseconds
with the device on the other side of the
world thanks to the internet
i am talking about milliseconds guys
this is a huge
thing and that's the main reason of why
the internet
is one of the most important thing that
mankind created
i hope i was able to explain intuitively
what the internet represents however
there is also something else very
important
that i have to say i want to tell you
the bookish definition of the internet
the internet is the network of the
networks
let me repeat the internet is the
network
of the networks i believe that you got
this but
i would like to make this definition
more meaningful to you
firstly think about your own harm maybe
you have a lot of devices that can
connect to the internet
for example computers mobile phones
televisions game consoles tablets
and many many more similarly most people
have many devices with an
internet connection in their home just
like you
right in the same way you can think
about a company
or an enterprise that has a huge number
of devices
and you know that there are many
companies and enterprises
in all over the world so as you notice
there are many small or medium-sized
lands
spread all over the world and all these
lands
on the visual represent these networks
as a result the combination of all these
networks
stand for the internet itself this is
very important
the combination of all these networks
stands for
the internet itself in other words we
are talking about a huge system
in which almost all electronic devices
in the world
used to communicate with each other by
the way
there is a very important part here to
understand
on the visual we called this structure
that is in the middle of the visual as
the internet
and you will see such a representation
in many resources
you can usually see a cloud logo in
order to represent the internet
but in fact the internet is this fixed
structure you see
formed by a combination of all these
networks
and this structure in the middle okay
this is very crucial guys what i am
trying to say is
when you only see such a representation
you should think that there are millions
of lands that are connected to it
even if these lands don't appear
individual
okay and the internet is a huge system
that includes all lands in the world
so i hope that you understand better
reason of the bookish definition of the
internet the
internet is the network of networks
wonderful and you can think of this
structure
as the heart of the internet for example
when we connect this lan to the heart of
the internet
with this cable this lan will be
included
in the internet and it can communicate
other devices
that are connected to the internet you
catch the idea
so far we have learned what the internet
is
and how important routers are but what
exactly does connecting to the internet
look like
from a computer's perspective and we are
going to discuss this question in the
next lesson
see you guys soon bye
now we are going to discuss the meaning
of connecting to the internet
from the computer's perspective and i
believe that
it is very important to understand this
event
assume that we are in a home instead of
an
office and we have only one computer
therefore to be able to connect to the
internet
what we only need is a home router isn't
it
there is no need for a switch since we
don't have other devices
to connect to each other in this home
very good
by the way if you want we could use a
router device
instead of a home router device because
if you are aware
we want to use only the router feature
of the home router we don't need to use
the switch feature
of the home router right because there
is only one computer
in the environment i believe currently
you know which device actually does what
this should be logical to you
therefore i will assume that you know
what basic networking devices are doing
from now on and so far
you have learned that the connection
situation of the internet
is determined by whether the related
computer can send a packet to the
internet
or not and now i will try to make this
situation
more meaningful to you you are watching
this video
on the udemy.com website right i mean
let's say you are turning on your
computer
and entering udemy.com on your favorite
web browser
then you click on the video you are
watching right now
or any video you want to watch and as
soon as you click on one of these videos
your computer creates a packet and sends
this packet to udemy.com
over the internet the package firstly is
sent to home router
and then the home router sends the
package to udemy.com
over the internet and we can think of
this green packet
as your request message to udemy.com
a request message gives information to
udemy.com
about you want to watch the related
video okay this is very crucial
and after udemy.com receives your
request message
about watching a specific video it
naturally realizes that
you want to watch a video hence udemy
sends the related video to you
over the internet and there we go these
red packers
represent the pieces of the video that
udemy
sent to you in other words the video you
are watching right now
by the way there's a very important
thing about this process
let me explain while you are watching
any video on udemy
udemy sends it to you piece by piece
and we call this process streaming
i think you have heard of this concept
before
and with the help of streaming
technology you can watch the videos
uninterruptedly
or without any problem and to be able to
show
this piece by piece sending process
better now
i have opened a random video on
udemy.com
you can see that the video is being sent
to my computer
from udemy.com piece by piece thanks to
the ability
to send videos piece by piece we can
watch the video
without requirement for all the video to
reach
our computer for example imagine you
want to watch a one
hour video and assume that your internet
speed
is so slow if you couldn't watch
this video before the whole video
reached your computer
it will be very bad for you right
fortunately
the process doesn't work like that okay
and in addition this transmission time
varies depending on the speed of our
internet
the faster our internet speed is the
sooner
the video will reach our computer it's
that simple
i hope in this way you have a better
understanding of
what these red packets are great
as a result connecting to the internet
reverser
you can send some packets to the
internet and
you can receive some packets from the
internet
and here the router or home router in
this situation
plays a very important role the home
router
gives the packets it receives from the
computer to the internet
and gives the packets it receives from
the internet
to the computer in summary packet
transmission
is the basis of connecting to the
internet or
communicating with a computer on the
other side of the world
meanwhile when we enter udemy.com
we communicate with very powerful
computers
that actually belongs to udemy.com
and we call this special computers
server
servers do not differ fundamentally from
normal computers
however since the servers will exchange
packets with thousands of normal
computers at the same time
servers must be much more powerful
computers
in terms of hardware compared to normal
computers
because as you know too many people
access udemy.com at the same time
i mean too many people access servers of
udemy.com at the same time
and at this moment let me tell you what
i mean
when i say servers of the udemy if you
remember
we talked about the importance of the
single point of failure
and load balancing before and this is
true for servers
of udimeter there is not a single udemy
server
in the world udemy has a lot of servers
distributed around different parts of
the world
the location of one of these servers is
the best for you
and you communicate with this best
suited server
it's that simple as a result when you
want to enter udemy.com
you are actually communicating with one
of the suitable udemy servers
for you so while some of you communicate
with the same server some of you will
communicate
with a different server but at the end
of today you will all
get the same content therefore thanks to
distributed
servers udemy prevents single point of
failure
and provides load balancing please think
about it a little
okay by the way
of course there are many details behind
the transmission
of packets but you can think of it in
this way
as the simplest logic and that's all i
need to say
in this lesson see you guys soon bye
in this lesson we will shortly talk
about the white area network
or briefly van which is a very important
type of network
for the internet in a simple manner you
can think of van
as a network consisting of a combination
of different plants
for example with the combination of
these two lamps
we can create a van or combination of
this land this then and this land
we can create another one okay and in
order to understand better
the logic of van we can talk about the
company example
let's say we have a growing company and
we opened
some offices in different parts of the
world and we want these offices
to be in the same network even if they
are far apart
and this is where the wide area network
comes into play by using
van we can create a special network for
our requirements
let's say this is one of our lan and
this is our another lan
and they are located in different parts
of the world and
we want to create a van for our company
by using these two lands
but the question is how do we do that
let's see
let's say our boss wants us to establish
a special network
for these lands i mean he wants
the computers in these two different
offices to work
as if they're in the same environment so
our guy is van if we create a van
these lands can communicate as if they
are in the same environment
but there is an important point to
consider here
thanks to the internet we can already
enable these lands
to communicate right as you know the
internet
stands for the network of networks this
means that the internet itself
represents connecting millions of lands
together hence if these lands
are already connected to the internet
computers in lan 1
and computers in lan 2 can already
communicate
over the internet this is obvious so
the question is if these offices can
already communicate with each other
over the internet why we need another
special network
as a van please be careful
communication over the internet directly
and communication over a special van
belongs to a company is a whole
different tank
so i want you to think about that
question for a short time
and try to answer it
if you have noticed the internet is a
public network
i mean the internet has no owner and it
belongs to everyone
any person can connect to the internet
whenever
and wherever he wants for this reason it
is obvious that
this public and huge network can have
security related problems in information
transfer
between different locations you know
hackers
are everywhere and they are in this
public and huge network too
and to be able to answer the question i
just asked better
i want to give you a very good example
let's say this computer wants to send
an important file related to the company
to this computer
and after the file is sent to this
computer
there will be no any problem because
this transmission process
took place within this lan this lan
is a private network for this office
an outsider cannot directly access this
land
without your permission this is very
important hence
file transmission operation in this land
is a secure operation
in general everything is good so far
but what would happen if this file was
sent
to the other office over the internet
let's see now the scenario is the same
again
we need to send a file related to the
company but this time
we must send this file to the other
office of the company
as you can see the file passes through
the public network
isn't it and this is where the problems
appear
just think about it this part of the
internet is an
absolute public network this means that
if you send the file
over the internet like that there is no
guarantee that
no one from the outside can't see this
file
or worst no one from the outside can't
change this file
as i said before hackers are everywhere
and the possibility of these issues are
generally not low
hence it is important to remember that
there is a possibility
for a problem when you send this file
about the company
over the internet directly especially if
it is a very important file
about the company it is very vital to be
careful
and a special one for the company is a
solution
to such problems in general setting up a
van
is a costly and not easy task but
fortunately
there are various methods of setting up
a van
and now we will only talk about the most
popular
and cost effective van method and this
method is then
by using vpn i am sure that you have
heard of
vpn before it stands for virtual
private network and people usually use
vpn
to access restricted websites because
vpn ensures are anonymity and it
encrypts our data
before signing the packet hence this
gives us
high security in general and while
creating
vans by using vpn technology we take
advantage of these features
of vpn but the most important feature
you should know about vpn is the
tunneling
this feature of vpn provides privacy
anonymity and security to us by creating
a special
network connection over a public network
this is really very important
i want to repeat this again vpn
tunneling
provides privacy anonymity and security
to us
by creating a special network connection
over a public network however frankly
speaking
a physical tunnel isn't created here
this is very crucial
tunneling technology makes the packet
acts
as if it is going through a physical
tunnel but
i won't repeat it again this is not a
physical tunnel
this tunnel visual just represents the
high security connection
between line 1 and lan 2. you can think
of it in this way
this tunnel visual just stands for the
high security
for the connection between these routers
it's that simple
by the way of course the packet will
pass through main routers on the
internet
in order to reach its destination just
as you have learned before
however since vpn uses tunneling
it will be almost impossible to
interfere with this packet
from the outside great
i hope that you got the channeling
conceptually
but i want to take a closer look at it
so first
we sent our file to the router and there
we go
and at this moment there will be some
changes
on the packet but before doing these
changes
first of all you should know that vpn
tunnelling
is set up between these routers this is
very crucial
and we call this site-to-site vpn
this method is very popular while
creating a van
between offices and thanks to the
tunneling
our file saved reaches lanter you know
but the question is if tunneling is not
a physical tunnel
as shown in the picture what exactly is
it
let's see i will use an analogy
to explain this let's say you need to
send a letter
from land1 to lanter so you should give
the letter you wrote
to a postman right the postman can take
this letter
to its destination and suppose you are
not putting this letter
in an envelope this means that the
postman
can read the letter if he wants this is
obvious
you can think of the postman in this
example as the public internet
on the other hand if you had put this
letter in an
envelope first and gave it to the
postman in this way the postman
wouldn't be able to read it this is
obvious hence
the process of putting glitter in an
envelope
represents the tunneling itself so in
the real scenario
we had to put this yellow packet into
another packet
and there we go assume that the yellow
packet
is in the red packet it's just like
putting the letter
in an envelope that's the whole idea
about tunneling wonderful and at this
moment
i want to ask you a question and my
question is that
is this packet really in safe right now
i mean can't the postman open the
envelope
and find out the information in it if he
really wants to
just think about it you got the point
right even though we have increased the
security
of the packet by applying tunneling
there are still
some problems and this is where
encryption
comes into play suppose that you encrypt
your letter
in a way that only people working in
your company can understand
in this case even if the postman opens
the envelope
he cannot obtain the information because
he will see non-understandable data he
will not
understand the encrypted information so
what we have to do is very simple right
we must encrypt
the original packet before putting it
into another packet
so let me back one step on the animation
and for this scenario we encrypt the
yellow packet
before putting it in the red packet and
then
we put this encrypted packet into the
red packet
and finally this packet is sent to land2
over the internet safely and there we go
it's that simple guys we encrypted the
original packet
and put it in another packet thus we
maximized the security of the packet
okay the term of tunneling comes from
here
because packet is safe is if it was
moving in your own private tunnel
i hope that i made this concept
understandable to you
and at this moment the router needs to
get the original packet
and to be able to do this the router
first eliminates
the outside packet right and then it
needs to decrypt
the encrypted packet so that it can
obtain the original packet
and after the router gets the original
packet
it looks inside the packet and learns
its destination
and sends the packet to its destination
and there we go
as a result with the help of the van by
using vpn
we can securely send company related
information
from one lan to another but never forget
that
there is no such thing as 100 percent
security
this means there may be always a
security vulnerability
for every system however currently
one network's built by using vpn
technology
are quite satisfactory in terms of both
budget
and security okay i believe
everything is good so far but some of
you curious
can think about equation you probably
think like
i constantly use the internet in daily
life
i send mail to my friends i use
e-commerce website and i do
all of these over the internet so since
the internet is a public
network are all these operations
insecure
the answer is both yes and now let me
explain
assume that you want to make an
operation on amazon.com
and let's say you had to enter some
information
about your credit card while purchasing
a product
since this information will be sent as a
packet over the internet
to one of the servers of amazon.com we
absolutely don't want anyone from the
outside
to see the information about our credit
card
as a solution to this an end-to-end
encryption method is used
between our computer and the destination
server
and since the packet is encrypted nobody
from the outside can see the information
about our credit card except the server
of
amazon.com this is the main logic behind
the end-to-end
encryption only the end points can
decrypt
the packet and obtain to original data
okay
however this kind of encryption was not
used in the past
and this situation made it easy for
hackers
imagine that the information about your
credit card
was directly obtained by a hacker in
pure text
this is terrible right but thanks to
end-to-end
encryption we eliminate this problem
and finally i am going to ask you a
question
and then i am going to finish the lesson
now you know what one is right in
summary ban
represents the networks we create by
combining different plans
in this case my question is what is the
largest white area network
in the world the answer comes to your
mind rapidly
isn't it the internet itself is the
largest wide orient network
in the world however i want to remind
you again
please note that a company's van
created with vpn is different from the
internet
while one of these vans is completely
special to the company
the internet is owned by everyone in the
world
and yeah that's all i would like to say
about run
see you guys soon
we have learned a lot of information
about network devices until now
and in this lesson we will look at a few
more cases
by using these devices let's say we have
two
offices belongs to the same company and
suppose that there are
100 meters between these offices
if you are aware this distance is very
short
in this case what i am wondering is
whether or not we can connect which one
and switch to direct to each other
to create a lan and the answer is
we can definitely do this because as you
know that
we use switches to create lands
therefore
we can create a lan by connecting these
switches to each other
even if they are not in the same
environment but please note that
the distance is very short between these
offices
if this distance were not too short it
is impossible to connect these switches
and create a lan meanwhile
these types of lands can be called
campus area network
or briefly can since these types of
networks
are generally used on university
campuses
okay on the other hand you know that we
can also connect these two offices
by using van with vpn but please note
that
vat and lan are different kinds of
network types this is important
and you can see the package sent with
tunneling
in the animation and
there we go yep i believe
so far everything is good but i want to
ask you
a question which one do you think is
more secure
when with vpn or lan created by
connecting switches directly
please think about it for a short time
and try to answer it
the answer is so simple isn't it a lan
is always more secure than a van because
in the communication within the lan the
packet never
passes over the internet the packet
always moves
on our own cable on the other hand even
if the packet
is protected in the van the packet still
passes over the internet
and as you know there is never such a
thing as
100 percent security even if the packet
is protected
with tunneling and encryption so
to summarize both of these methods are
secure
but lan is more secure this is obvious
however there is a condition that a van
is almost as secure as alarm and we call
private van
for this type of van by the way we
haven't talked about
this one type before i mean this is
different
from man with vpn because the line
between offices
is dedicated for the company you request
this line
from the isp and give a special money
for this line
thus the isp gives you a private line
that
only your company can use we call the
van created in this way
is private van okay and please remember
that
we were using public internet network
inven with vpn
and that's why we also call wemitvpn
is public van this is very crucial in
addition
even if private van sounds great at the
first glance
it can be quite costly for this reason
it makes sense for an average company to
prefer public van
instead of private one you know public
van
provides us security that we definitely
cannot underestimate
right wonderful now
i want you to pay attention to one point
some of you may have
already noticed this but it will be good
to mention
in any case we use switch devices to
create
a lan while we use routers to create a
van
this is very vital i want to repeat this
again
we use switches to create a lan
while we use routers to create a van
this means we can not create a van by
using switch devices
because a van fundamentally represents
connection of different plants
with the help of one different plants
can
act as if they are in the same
environment and you know that
if you want to connect different plants
we definitely
need a router for this task you got the
point
and now i want to talk a little bit
about the router
until now i have always explained the
router
as an internet related device however it
isn't
the main task of the router is to
connect different networks that's it
you should realize that these networks
may be in different parts of the world
or maybe in the same office it really
doesn't matter
and in this slide you can see that two
different plants in the same office
are connected to each other thanks to
the router device
suppose that one of these networks is
related to the marketing unit of the
company
and the other related to the software
unit and
as you know if we want different
networks to communicate with each other
we should use a router in the animation
you can see that lan 1 and land2
communicate
through the router and there we go
great and here i want to give you
additional information about the router
i want you to focus on
the cables of the router if you are
aware
each cable is connected to a different
network
i mean one of the cables is connected to
lan 1
one of the cables is connected to line 2
and one of the cables
is connected to the internet this is the
case for the router
the router connects different networks
you know for this reason
each cable connected to a port on the
router represents a different network
okay by the way you may have wondered
why different networks
are needed within the same office as a
matter of fact
this is a common situation in real life
i mean
you may want different units in the
office to be in different networks
this might be offsearch for an office
with 4 computers
however imagine an office with 50
computers in it
dividing these computers into units
increases hierarchy
and order never forget that
as you can see the basic principles are
the same everywhere
by using these basic principles we can
enable devices
in different parts of the world to
communicate and
we can enable devices in the same office
to communicate
both of them represents the same task i
think
you understand this concept very well
and
that's all i want to say in this lesson
see you guys soon
in one of our previous lessons i told
you we purchased this cable
that came to our home from isp but i
haven't mentioned
what exactly isp is and in this lesson
we are going to discuss what is the isp
and why it is so
important the internet service provider
or briefly isp is responsible for the
transmission of packets
from one location to another if you
remember
we have learned that there are a lot of
routers
in the heart of the internet i'm talking
about this structure
and you can think of the isp as the
mechanism that controls
all these routers in this structure for
example
there are actually many routers in this
globalizer
similarly there are main routers in this
regional sp
but to simplify the concept i didn't
visually show
the routers within the isps however
i want you to imagine that the routers
distributed around the world are
controlled
by these isps this is very crucial think
of it
as each isp controls specific routers
and packets are sent from one location
to another location
over these routers we previously talked
about how the packet travels
from one point to another via routers
understanding this situation is the
first condition to understand the isp
what i am trying to say is certain isps
are responsible for certain routers i
want you to imagine that
every isp you see in this picture is
responsible
for certain routers okay but i am
removing them
from the visual for the simplicity of
the concept
in addition the isp model you see here
is a simplified model but even if the
model is simple
it is enough to understand the most
important parts
of the concept let's start with basic
definition
of the isp isps represent
companies that serve us so that we can
connect to the internet
and of course they charge a certain fee
for this service
you cannot connect to the internet
without an isp
think of isp as the structure that
allows you
to connect to the internet and isp
is not a single structure there are
hundreds of thousands of isps in the
world
and all these isps come together to form
the structure you see
individual there is few isp individual
i know that but i can say that there are
hundreds of thousands of isps
in real life the most common isp type in
the world
is local asp and now i want to start
with it
the first step of connecting to the
internet is to communicate
with the local asp and local isps are
generally
responsible for small area
communications for example
the communications of two different
plants in the same neighborhood
or communication of lands located in
neighborhoods
close to each other let's say we live in
the usa
and these two homes are located in the
same neighborhood
if this computer wants to communicate
with this computer
the connection is provided directly over
this local asp this is obvious
you can see this on the animation
the packet passes through different
routers at
local sp and reaches its destination
but in general since the local isp is
responsible for the communication of
small
areas the packet can also pass through
only one router
before reaching its destination you can
think of this local asp
as the isp that only connects lands
within a neighborhood
of course a local asp can connect
different neighborhoods but in this
scenario
let's say it doesn't therefore one
router can be enough to connect them
you got the point and
in this visual you can see an example of
a small local asp
office and we call these offices point
of presence
or briefly pub in fact
routers distributed over the internet
are included
in these paths and in this five in other
words in this office
routers are on the left side in addition
you have probably noticed that there are
other devices
than routers because sometimes we must
do different configurations
with different devices hence app must
save
routers switches servers and so on
but the device we use to connect
different networks to each other
is the router you know for this reason
we will only focus on writers
and in our previous lessons the routers
on the internet visual
were actually representing pubs spread
over the world
and in order to explain this better i
want to talk
on a different image but in this image
i want to think of different tassels and
offices connected to local sb2
and locally sp3 i mean we won't talk
about these songs
you got the point and there we go
as you can see a home and small office
connect to a pub over localized speeder
so this pub is the first point to be
able to connect to the internet
for this home and this office this
should be clear to you
by the way if you are aware local sb2
has four paths you might think that
thanks to these four paths
local b2 connects different
neighborhoods
and in this way lands in different
neighborhoods
can communicate over localized b2
effectively
and from here we can draw the following
conclusion
some local asps can have more than one
pub however
some local asps can only have one pop
this depends on the size of the local
asp
for example if a local asp connects four
different neighborhoods
it may have four different paths but if
a local asp
connects only one neighborhood it has
only one pup
you catch the idea and if you want to do
more detailed studies on this topic
you will see many resources on the
internet with raw dragons
you should be aware that these icons
actually represent the water
within the pub there are many pubs
distributed all over the world
and routers are in these paths it's that
simple
at this moment i want you to imagine
that there are
hundreds of thousands of local asps in
the world
and these local aspects connect to
regional aspects
that are larger than them this means
that different local asps
communicate over regional airspace for
example local sp2
communicates with local asp3 over the
original sp1
as a matter of fact you can think of
local aspects
connect neighborhoods and regional
aspects
connect cities in a country it's that
simple
i won't repeat this again you can think
of local asps
connect neighborhoods or small areas and
regional recipes
connect cities in a country okay
meanwhile there is one regional sp in
this simplified model we use
but in real life a country can have main
regional airspace
and all local aspies and regional aspies
combine
in order to create network of a country
in summary the first step to connecting
to the internet
is local asp and this line represents
the line we purchased
from the local isp right every home or
office
must purchase such a line from the
relevant isp
to connect to the internet and if you
examine your home router carefully
you can see the cable coming from your
isp
wonderful now let's suppose that
this computer and this computer want to
communicate with each other
by the way these two homes are located
in the usa
but they are in different cities as a
result
they are connected to different local
aspects this is obvious
so in this situation how will this local
sp communicate with this local asp
let's see in fact this is where the
original sp1
comes into play in general the original
asp is
engaged in the communication of devices
in the same countries
but in different cities if you look
carefully at the animation
local isps communicate over the regional
asp
this is obvious right and there we go
and at this moment some of you may be
wondering why there is no direct link
from
localized p2 to localize b3 this is an
expected question just think about it
if we connect localize this directly the
hierarchy is broken
i mean you see very few localized piece
in this scenario
but in real life there can be many local
sps
even in the same city and if we connect
them all together
complexity will definitely occur and we
don't want to increase
the complexity of this system it is
already quite complex isn't it
and that's why we use a central
hierarchical isp structure
as you see individual with the minimum
number of connections
between isps we ensure that all isps
communicate with each other
it's that simple so far
we have talked about local asp and
regional isp
also the computers that communicate with
each other
were always in the usa but what if
computers in different countries
want to communicate with each other and
this is where
the global asp comes into play you may
think that
the global isp connects devices in
different countries in general
as you know there's an ocean between the
usa
and china so if a device in the usa
and a device in china wants to
communicate it must be a global isp
that provides disconnection we cannot
connect these two devices
with only local asp and regional asp
and as you can see in the image there
are multiple global isps
and these global asps are the part of
the hierarchy
and by using them these two computers
can communicate with each other
let's assume that this computer wants to
communicate with this computer
in this case the packet will first go to
the localized speaker you know
and then go to the regional sp1
and the packet has two options at this
moment
this pad or this pad in other words
global sp1 or global sp3
i hope you understand that this
selection is determined
by the routers in the original sp1 each
router
makes a choice and as a result of these
choices
the router's patch is determined let's
say
the packet will be forwarded to global
sp1 and there we go
by the way another packet that will pass
through original sv1
may go to the global sb tree next time
who knows
you catch the idea anyway afterwards
let's say that the packet will be sent
from global sb1
to globalize between and there we go
and at this stage the packet can be sent
to local sb6 or directly to the original
sb2
or globalize b3 either way
it will reach its destination what i am
trying to say is
the packet can follow different paths
and i want to show you
some of these paths for example from
global asp2
to local sb6 regional sb2
local sb7 and destination or
from global asb 2 to direct regional asp
2
local ace b7 and destination or
from global asp 2 to global sb 3
regional sb2 localized b7
and destination again all of them
are suitable paths you should also have
noticed a situation here
if the destination of the packet was
this harm
the packet could reach its destination
directly over localized v6
without going over regionalized feature
this means that
some local aspects can directly connect
with global airspace
without a regional asp this is very
important
as you know local asps represent small
companies
and in some cases these small companies
may want a direct connection with a
global asp
to provide a faster internet experience
to its customers
actually there are two ways for this
kind of connection in general
if a local asp connects directly with a
global isp
its location can be very suitable for
this purpose
i mean related global asp can already
have an infrastructure
on this location however if the related
global asp
doesn't have an infrastructure in this
location a lot of extra money
must be paid for this connection but
local asp company
to the global asp company you catch the
idea
and for this package on the global asp2
let's say
it will go to the original isp2 instead
of local sb6
or global sb3 okay and from here
packet will go to the localized b7 and
there we go
as you can see localase b7 is connected
directly
to the destination line therefore
locally sb7 knows that
where it will send the packet and
finally the home run receiving the
packet sends it
to the destination computer voila
as a result you have learned how
computers in two different regions of
the world
communicate over the internet you also
learned
the relationship between the internet
routers and isp with each other
and in the next lesson we are going to
cover two more scenarios
related to the isp concept see you guys
in a moment
let's say we are in belgium this is our
home
and we want to connect to a newly
established website
called abcx.com the owners of the
website
have limited financial power for this
reason
they have only one server on the usa
so to be able to reach abcx.com
our request message must pass over at
least one globalism
this is obvious you can see the whole
process
on the animation
and after the server of the abcx.com
receives the request message in exchange
for it
abcx.com creates a response message
this response message contains
information about the web page
we want to enter it includes images
videos html file and everything
related to the web page meanwhile if you
don't know what an html file is
you can think of it as the skeleton of a
web page
in a simplest manner and after
generating the response message
the server must send it to us however
the path preferred by the response
message will be different
from the path preferred by the request
message
please pay attention to this on the
animation
there is no way to know the exact part
of a message beforehand
since routers can make different choices
each time
i mean the path for a message is always
determined
on the way never forget that
and as soon as we receive the response
message
the website appears in our web browser
in summary when you want to enter a
website
you first send a request message to the
server of website
and the web server receiving your
request message sends you
a response message which contains all
information
about the web page you want to enter and
when this message comes to you your web
browser
learns all information from this
response message
and displays the related web page in
your web browser
and the surprising thing is every time
you want to enter
a website this process happens again
however since this process takes place
in milliseconds
you don't realize that there are complex
operations
in the background and now
let's try to enter google.com instead of
abcx.com
and see what happens you know google is
quite different from
abcx.com since it is a giant company
for instance unlike abcx.com
google has many servers distributed all
around the world
and with this distributor server
structure google
provides a much more efficient and fast
service to its customers
and let's say one of these servers is
not far from
our home therefore when we want to enter
google.com or
when we want to get any service from
google
we will probably connect to this server
which is close to us okay
for this reason the process will be much
faster
in fact this is the main reason why big
companies put many servers
in different locations around the world
they want customers
to communicate with them in the fastest
and most efficient way
and the distributed server structure is
a great solution
for such a desire i believe you catch
the idea
so when we want to request a service
from google
our request message will go to this
server close to us
you know that how the packet reaches the
related server
with the help of isps and you know that
what will happen after this stage
google sends us a response message
related to the servers we request
however
the time for google to communicate with
the customers is sometimes
not satisfactory for google and google
wants to increase distribute in general
fortunately google has a very good
solution
for this kind of issue called peering
but what exactly is peering let's see
peering is the technique which google
establishes a direct connection
with an isp to provide faster access
to its servers as you can see on the
animation
google connects directly with the local
asps
thus when we want to get a service from
google
we will be able to communicate directly
with google servers
without using isp infrastructures in
this way
google can communicate with the
customers much more effectively
and quickly at this moment everything is
good
but what about security since the number
of public pub
that packets pass through decreases
thanks to peering
security increases so much i mean the
packet goes
directly to google via local asp
in other words the packet does not use
public isp infrastructures
to communicate with google remember that
security is very important
to large companies and it is obvious
that
this direct connection decreases the
possibility to be obtained for the
package
from the outside wonderful
and last but not least i want to give
you an example
as you know youtube is owned by google
so when you want to watch a video on
youtube
you are actually using google's
distributed servers
around the world and you are all aware
that
youtube works very efficiently when you
want to watch
a video on youtube you can watch it very
well
you will not be interrupted whatsoever
the main reason for this
is the distributed server structure and
the peering infrastructure
of google on the other hand you may
sometimes see phrases and interruptions
while watching videos on udemy because
udemy's infrastructure is not as strong
as google in general
of course udemy also uses a distributed
server structure
but this number is probably not as many
as google this is obvious
in addition udemy doesn't use peering
and you know that peering is a very
efficient technology
especially it increases the streaming
quality
and speed a lot but i can say that udemy
did a significantly good job overall
because
serving millions of people at the same
time
is a really challenging engineering
problem okay
in summary peering is a very effective
structure
is used by giant companies like google
amazon and so on you got the point
and finally i want to give you some
general information about
isp as you know global asps are
responsible
for the international communication i
can say that
although definitely not as many as the
original asp
there are a few global asps in the world
and you can guess that
the technical reasons for not having
only a single global asp
in the world we have talked about
similar things before
but in addition to these reasons like
load balancing and efficiency
there are also some financial reasons
for this
i mean setting up a global isb company
is a very costly business
at the beginning but it makes its owner
a lot of money
you know what i am saying right if you
have a lot of money
establishing a global asp company is a
good choice
it will probably make you smile with
time
by the way we also call the internet
backbone
to the network that global asp set up
with each other
familiarity to internet backbone term
can be useful for you
in the future in addition there are
structures
called internet exchange point in order
for the internet backbone
to work synchronously and for global
asps
to communicate with each other more
efficiently
and we briefly call these structures ixp
or ix never forget that
and the last thing i want to mention is
that you don't have to connect to a
local asp
in order to connect to the internet you
can directly connect to a regional sp
or global asp if these isps have a
service
for your location this means that you
can learn
which isps are serving value leave and
make your choice
according to this information it is
absolutely your decision
to choose the isp service you want okay
for example let's say this is our home
and we connect to the internet
via locally speaker however if we
request
we can also connect directly to the
internet the original sb1
this is possible what i am trying to say
is
if you want to get your isp service from
a certain company
and if this company doesn't serve your
location
you can contact the company and talk
about what you can do
if you give the required money to the
isp company
most regional asp and global asp can
provide you
the service you want that's it but for
normal users
this is very unnecessary normal users
only need to choose
one of the isp services in their
location and
benefit from it on the other hand if you
want to set up a local asb
company such a move may make sense
wonderful and we talked about the isp in
general
i think you got a lot of good
information
but if you want you can do more research
about the isp on the internet however
that's all i have to say in this course
you